welcome to the Apple Fans Christmas tech
guide of 2022 these are all going to be
between 25 and 100 and they're great
gifts for anyone that loves or has Apple
products like iPhones Macs and apple
watches so let's get started the first
product I want to show off is of course
the air tags from Apple yes this thing
is amazing it costs 29 by itself on
Amazon or if you buy a pack of four it's
99 so 25 bucks each and I actually have
four of these personally one of them is
right here on my keychain I have another
on my wife's keychain just in case
either of us lose our keys we can find
them easily and then I have one in each
of my cars just in case it's basically
the best and the only tracking accessory
that iPhone users should be using
because it's amazing and I do want to
give a little sneak teaser to a couple
of accessories for the air tags that I'm
going to reveal later on in this video
so watch the full thing for the next
accessory we have this genuine solid
titanium Apple watch Ultra band that's
on Amazon for only thirty four dollars
yes only 34 and Max has been wearing it
for the last couple of weeks and he
absolutely loves this because he
honestly expected it to feel a little
bit cheap but it was genuinely surprised
by how nice the quality is for the price
and the color matches the Apple watch
Ultra basically perfectly so for only 34
bucks you can't beat a genuine titanium
Apple watch band like this now for the
next tech gift we have another Apple
watch band but this is on a whole
different Spectrum this is a genuine
carbon fiber watch band from petaka and
yes it's real carbon fiber because you
can see the real layers so it's
incredibly lightweight I seriously think
this is the most lightweight Apple watch
band there is out there and it's super
strong and very high quality I love it
especially because of this little
magnetic clasp that's so easy to put on
and take off so definitely check this
out using the link below next up we have
these three awesome Chargers from our
Channel partner basis so let me quickly
show you each one of them the first is
their Mega attached 20 watt magnetic
wireless charging 10 000 milliamp hour
power bank which is really unique
because it comes with Max safe support
so it holds onto your iPhone while
giving it up to 7.5 watts of Qi charging
or 15 watts for Android and it has a
foldable kickstand right here so you can
put it down and watch videos just like
that and it also has a nice LED display
and even 20 watt PD full fast charging
using a cable plugging in directly from
the bank to your iPhone which is super
fast and right now you can get it for as
low as 38 dollars on Amazon with the
coupon enabled they also have their new
Ada man 20 000 milliamp hour 65 watt
charging brick which can fast charge
your iPhone four and a half times out of
either of the three outputs since both
of the USB a outputs can put out 30
watts of power and the USBC Port can
output 65 Watts which is enough to also
charge your MacBook with it and it also
comes with a cool display that can show
either the remaining battery life the
charging voltage or current and you can
get it for 48 on Amazon with the coupon
right now and then finally they have
their 100 watt 20 1000 milliamp hour
slim power pack which is very similar to
the 65 watt charger but it's super slim
and it offers up to 100 watts of
charging power which can fast charge
larger MacBooks or you can split the
power between multiple devices since it
has four fast charging ports and you can
get this one on Amazon with a coupon for
85 dollars right now so check all of
them out using the links below now
moving on to the next one this is my
all-time favorite wallet that both Max
and I use every day and even my wife
uses it it's the moft max safe wallet
stand and I absolutely love it because
it's super slim so I carry it in my
pocket or I can attach it to my iPhone
at any time it also comes with a
built-in kickstand that works very well
for watching videos and I currently have
four cards inside of it but apparently
my wife has five of them in there right
now so she loves it especially since
since her old Apple macsafe wallet can
only really hold three and right now you
can get one for as low as 16 on Amazon
so it's a great tech gift now moving on
to the next one we have probably the
best value Three in One Max save charger
out there the Halo lock from ESR which
basically comes with an adjustable Max
save charger for your iPhone which comes
with a built-in cooling fan which
increases the life of your battery long
term since it doesn't get hot while
charging and it also comes with a light
which you can switch off if it's
distracting on top of that you also have
a charger for your Apple watch and your
airpods as well so it's super convenient
and you can get it for just sixty
dollars on Amazon right now now before I
get into the next one I want to thank
our sponsor pulseway that's doing huge
holiday offers now with pulse way you
can centrally control all of your it
systems like desktops server servers and
network devices all at your fingertips
how cool is that whether you need to run
a script remotely connect to a system
reset a password or simply shut your
system off pulse way has you covered and
the best part it works from literally
every device check out their holiday
special offers through the link below
and secure the Limited Time pricing by
starting a trial right now now getting
back to those air tax accessories I
mentioned in the beginning we have this
one from pataka which is basically an
air tag holder with a keychain but if
you look closely it's actually a
multi-tool with a Phillips and flathead
screwdriver a little box cutter and an
allen key and you can find it on Amazon
for 59 or if you want to keep things
simple you can also get a Belkin
keychain holder like I use for both mine
and my wife's keys and you could get two
of these for 16 bucks on Amazon another
really cool air tag accessory is this
awesome air tag holder from pataka that
has this Loop which is secretly a USBC
to lightning charging cable so you'll
always have one with you wherever you go
and this one is also 59 bucks on Amazon
now if the Apple fan in your life has a
13 or 14 inch MacBook then the leather
laptop sleeve from extra is great
because it has a soft microfiber
interior for your MacBook as well as a
magnetic clasp to keep it closed and a
ton of sleeves on the outside for
carrying various files papers and
accessories and you can get it on sale
for 76 bucks right now now if the person
you're buying a gear 4 has a set of air
pods already then this right here is one
of the coolest accessories it's called
the Jura anchor and it simply plugs into
your lightning Port just like that and
it holds on incredibly well so you can
use the carabiner to attach it to
whatever you'd like so it's a very neat
idea because it doesn't require a full
airpods case and if you charge your
airpods using wireless charging then
you're not even gonna have to unplug it
at all in order to charge so I'm going
to leave a link to this down below
including the basic version or the
titanium versions below between 20 and
26 bucks so there you guys go that was
our full list of cool Christmas Tech
gifts for Apple Fans and of course we're
going to leave links to all of them down
in the description below and if you
enjoy this video click the circle about
to subscribe for more videos like this
one thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]